mom what are you talking about I always
have time for you hang on call you back
I've got something even hotter and
juicier last time don't move I'll be
right there
okay what do you have what is that code
for something you the moon landing was
faked the Illuminati hmm the Millennial
vote mercury is in retrograde meteors
are coming the midterm elections what
you have something for me or not
yeah sorry here you go my neighbors are
suing me for always parking on the bocce
court
what's bocce that's a big scoop hey want
to buy to my quarter pounder no I've got
leads to chase it's hotter and juicier
McDonald's new hotter and juicier 100%
fresh beef quarter pounder burger so
good they'll leave you speechless
[Music]